[Music]
gamer's old enough should remember
booting up Ridge Racer for the first
time this fantastic PlayStation launch
title was such a wonderful demonstration
of the new three-dimensional
capabilities of this new generation of
consoles so how curious it was that
before you got to the hot 3d car racing
action
you got to play this the loading screen
for Ridge Racer wasn't simply some now
loading text but a 2-d mini game that
had little to do with car racing in fact
it was a miniature version of Galaxian
and if you're able to defeat every
single enemy by the time Ridge Racer
loaded you got access to all 12 cars in
the game this novel concept blew
people's minds and it also distracted
them from the fact that the game was
loading and that was pretty important
back then Playstations rival the
Nintendo 64 boasted minimal load times
thanks to its cartridge technology so
for Sony's console to have access to it
get around by loading smaller games
while it certainly took the sting out of
that disadvantage so that this wonderful
concept see a massive explosion of
loading screen mini games did it change
the face of loading screens forever and
create an exciting new world of short
form play now we barely got to see any
at all but 20 years later that might be
about to change the point season 3
episode 4 the patent that gave us 20
years of loading screens
[Music]
the loading screen is a forum that
gaming owns holy and though they've
evolved over the years from disk swaps
to interactive screens they've remained
largely the same short sometimes long
periods of time where the game is loaded
to memory there's no way around the man
if you took the effort to taut up all
the time you've spent sitting in front
of loading screens your entire life it
would probably make for some depressing
reading that doesn't mean that some
developers haven't attempted to spice
them up be it the rotating crop of
Skyrim jockey estecado x' monologues in
the darkness Mass Effect One's
never-ending elevators or Assassin's
Creed's at fluctuation with fog halls
but for the most part we've spent the
past twenty years staring at texts and
images and that's because in November of
1995 Namco successfully secured a patent
for the right to have these minigames
before the main game is loaded the
patent reads unnecessary wastage of time
can be prevented by first loading the
smaller auxilary game program code into
the game's machine before the main game
program code is loaded then loading the
main game program code while the
auxilary game is running now I know what
you're about to say but Danny I've
played a bunch of minigames before the
main game is started like in Bayonetta
or FIFA in fact FIFA had a bunch of
different minigames that allowed you to
do anything from taking penalties to
practicing free kicks to running around
sticks like an this is true but
the crucial difference here is that
these aren't what the patent calls
auxilary games FIFA and Bayonetta
basically allowed to play a tiny slice
of the main games code the patent isn't
interested in this it secures the
loading of auxilary games which are
games that are totally separate from the
code being loaded for the main game so
like Galaxian being loaded before Ridge
Racer
[Music]
the most frustrating thing about all
this is that there were actually
auxilary games before that Payton was
granted invader load on the Commodore 64
had this little space invaders game as
the game loaded and I was back in 1987
so really the Payton shouldn't have been
granted in the first place who knows
what weird and wonderful auxilary games
we may have enjoyed over the past 20
years couldíve Espenson World of
Warcraft's login screen playing a
Warcraft mini game maybe we could have
enjoyed the original Metal Gear during
Metal Gear Solid 4 as a rage ously long
install screen sure we probably would
have had a load of absolute garbage
minigames and bunches of 8-bit era
classics regurgitated for the sake of it
but this pattern might well have just an
itis of dozens of memorable auxilary
games
who knows if dev teams would have
relished this type of short form design
during the development process but it
never happened instead we wasted
hundreds probably thousands of minutes
staring at seven letters thankfully
though there is light at the end of the
loading screen the pattern was set to
last for twenty years as of November
27th 1995 which means on November 27th
of this year developers will be free for
the first time in two decades to develop
auxilary games once again so could it be
that the auxilary game a relic of game
development pass is said to have a
renaissance in 2016 well here's hoping
so because despite the massive evolution
in technology in the past 20 years it
doesn't look like loading screens are
going away anytime soon
you